good morning everybody it being 10
o'clock I'm going to open the public
hearing
for I think it's Senate Bill 563 does
anybody have an agenda um if you would
Allegiance pledge aliance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
for so for those of you watching at home
um we are
going we are going to be uh going into a
recess but the we are going to be
holding a public hearing for Senate bill
5 63 so everybody knows it is
anticipated that the language will be
changed quite dramatically so um you
know just keep that in mind while you
are testifying or listening to testimony
just so the public is aware uh the the
hearing I stand corrected is for the
non-gain amendment to Senate Bill 563
which is
recess
e
okay we're going to open the public
hearing on the non gerine
Amendment the amendment number and
H or 4
H
um does everyone have a copy of the
amendment
okay we have um anyone here to testify
on the
amendment
yeah yeah I suppose I should do that I
don't know they didn't specifically say
the amendment he
the oh think he's not allowed to do it
he
testifies chairman Roy you're up hey
thanks um good morning everyone we're
here for the introduction of this
Amendment um this amendment that you
have before you um I'm going to propose
we change it
drastically um and the proposal is going
to narrow it down to like a paragraph
that's going to Define tency an
exception to tency instead of all this
other stuff which I want to discuss
during the work session so that's going
to be the limit of my testimony on this
because this what's before us is going
to be altered significantly shortly so
um if I anyone has any questions I just
just ask you to hold them we're going to
discuss this in depth
shortly um and to anyone who is going to
testify I would recommend you might hold
off too much but you have a question
yeah
I I just uh have a question about the
process the process so we have an
amendment that's before us yeah and it
may be altered in the work session and
the function the way that would
be this Amendment would be um come in as
a a different amendment is that cor same
Amendment but it'll be the same
Amendment but it will have a different
number or something on it no it'll have
the same number it'll just be Rewritten
um as long as it's gerain to this
amendment okay and we'll do all that in
the work session we'll do all that and
then we and then roduce it as then it
eventually gets exact as part of the
bill yeah if it gets ad when we do that
if it's adopted yep and we'll be voting
on adopted today or does that take place
today just working we won't take we're
not going to vote on anything till
Wednesday thank you represent
representative Roy you have to sit back
questions yes representative scitec
representative Roy I think the that's
not the process I think the process is
that you don't amend an amendment we're
going to have a new Amendment with a new
number that may be based off of this
modification this but this won't go
forward that would be what OS does when
we send over the new language I'm sorry
if OLS assigns a new number when we send
over the
language wow okay and we'll have to
reintroduce the new one which is why I'm
trying to cut this yeah it it will be a
new amendment number though they'll will
assign us a whole new number I think
that's where there was confusion with
representative Newman yeah bottom line
is this is not going to be what we're
working right right but there will be a
new there will be a new amendment number
because we are it'll be just a different
Amendment
okay
um I I'm not sure if this is Nick Norman
yeah Nick Norman thank you very much for
the opportunity to speak with you based
on what chairman Roy said I'll keep my
comments quite brief because I
understand that the whole amend is going
to be largely re written um I work as an
advocate for housing
providers I normally I I wrote to
everyone last night you got an email
from me I'm normally before Judiciary
and commerce so you don't see me too
much because you don't often take up
landlord tenant bills but I've been
working for about 13 or more years
advocating for property owners around
the state I'm very active in that with
anything involving new landlord tenant
law we have about 3,500 members that
we're in touch with and we send out
legislative upd updates during the
legislative season every week so I let
you know that to say that I I'm very
involved in landlord tenant law um I'm
often in the process of working out
compromises and languages and helping
people to come to some win-win
situations and we I have a core team of
experienced investors and attorneys and
we'd be very happy to help you with this
language and I would like to be offer
that um the concept I think is important
and needed to be able to quickly remove
illegal unauthorized you know people
that are illegally taking possession of
a property the idea that it would have
to be written leases is extremely
Troublesome because many many people
have valid reasons to be at a property
that it's not under a written Le
so um I can see that there's quite a
large number of issues with the way is
currently drafted um but I do believe
it's something that would be needed to
be able to quickly remove illegal
squatters um so um that's basically it I
would I would love to be a resource to
you my I'll give you my phone number is
I'll give you my heart to remember email
yahoo.com and I would invite any
questions thank you Mr and I plan to be
here during your work session if you
want to thank you any further are there
any are there any
questions seeing none thank you very
Marson good
morning good morning I will try and keep
this brief also my name is Jessica
marison I'm a ten organizer with gsop
but I am here speaking on behalf of
myself today um the reason I oppose this
bill and think it's um a horrible
overreach is it passes and removes many
due processes in the process of been
acting so when um the owner of a
property or law enforcement acting at
the request of the owner May without
need for legal process immediately
remove such person uh a lot of times I'm
helping tenants who were illegally
removed with a 548 to get back in their
apartment um this removes all due
process for a person to be able to stand
up and say this isn't right um the next
part of without due process is with no
advanced notice being required um guilty
of a misdemeanor Criminal Trespass and
any property left occupied dwelling
shall be deemed as abandoned um this is
already hard enough for many tenants
trying to leave their property to get
stuff out within 7 days I can relate
this to a personal um story though where
I was living at um for the past two
months I did not have a lease I did not
have anything written in a contract um I
was quite desperate to get out of my car
and into a home so fast forward to about
a week and a half ago my person I was
renting a room from decided they wanted
to do something different with that room
they started picking up my stuff and
trying to box it luckily the police were
called I had to keep tape recording out
of safety and the cops reminded them
that there is a process for this and
that I legally live there and they can't
go about doing
this so they thought they were in the
right by doing this if we have a
landlord that thinks they're in the
right you have an opportunity here where
someone could be illegally removed from
their place and lose everything they
have I at least have a little safety
there of the seven days to go back and
luckily our Police
Department did know the rules to be able
to let them know and in my experience
not every police officer knows these
laws um this was seems to be something
created to fix another problem and done
horribly wrong um so I be be
oppose this bill and hope everyone does
Kremer good
morning good morning my name is Ben
Kramer um I represent New Hampshire
youth movement um I live in New Market
um my organization is a young people's
organization across the state we have
over a 100 dedicated members more than
5,000 supporters um all ages 15 to 30 in
the state and I'm here to testify on
behalf of young Granite Staters and as a
young gr Stater myself um I oppose this
amendment we also oppose the underlying
bill I'll keep it brief knowing that
there are changes coming to this
amendment and would caution you to uh
apply what I'm about to say to any uh
propos proposed changes I think the
biggest concern with this amendment is
around due process and unintended
consequences um both for this amendment
and that's a concern that I would apply
to any future changes as others have
said and will say in this testimony um
many people in this state particularly
young people living in their first
apartment college students and their
their first time away from home don't
have access to written leases many
people don't have a written lease and
that's fine um and this this amendment
would Place him in extremely precarious
position um I myself when I was in my
first apartment living on my own in
college I did not have access to a
written lease easily didn't really know
how that works it's very concerning to
me to see legislation that would make
those people in a very precarious
situation to be removed without due
process um to set the stakes here I
think it's important to to underline
that any law that makes tency more
precarious in this current housing
crisis that we're in it will increase
homelessness and New Hampshire is
already the fastest rising rate of
homelessness in the country last year
homelessness Rose 52% in the state and
that is the fastest rising rate of
homelessness in the country so I think
it's important to appreciate the stakes
here um and for this amendment that
makes tendency extremely
precarious um and any future amendments
related to tendency I would ask you to
bear that in mind um we need to protect
due process for eviction we need to
require good cause for eviction and give
tenants their right to Due Process
before they're removed from housing um
and I would urge the committee to oppose
this amendment um I would also imagine
that I mean I'll read the amendment when
it is posted but um for the future
amendment I would bet that if it affects
the if it makes tendency more precarious
I would oppose that too so thank you
thank
you representative Murphy thank you I
actually just have a question on the
chair yeah um since what
we're pardon
me yeah um but my question is what we're
talking about and what people are
testifying on is the amendment as
written and we've been told that there's
going to be changes so will the people
that have come to testify have the
opportunity to testify to whatever the
final Amendment as proposed is because
we're they're limiting testimony based
on the fact that we assume there will be
changes made so I just want to I want to
understand whether or not they'll have
the opportunity for input once we really
actually have the amendment is proposed
yes perfect thank you you're
Barry Mr Barry allow me to um tell you
thank you for coming back to join us
again today my pleasure thank you for
having
me for the for the record my name is
Elliott Barry I'm here as a private
citizen having retired from New
Hampshire legal assistance in
2023 uh after 47 years uh I think in 47
years it's fair to say that I've
represented more tenants than anybody in
the history of for better for worse uh
than anybody in the history of the state
of New Hampshire
um I want to start out again by being
clear that I my testimony which is
strongly against the amendment as
written uh is not meant to uh impune
anybody's motives but there are plenty
of unintended consequences and before I
point them out though I'd like to say
something um to make something very
clear this is all Arisen I believe in
the te in the uh context of a national
sudden National scandal about squatters
um based on on cases that allegedly
happened in New York and happened in
California where Apparently after 30 to
60 days of being somewhere you become
you have some kind of right as a tenant
please understand in New Hampshire with
one exception the law does not recognize
any squatter's rights what is that one
exception if you openly and notoriously
occupy real estate for 20 years then you
have rights to adverse possession that
is the totality of squatter's rights in
the state of New
Hampshire so the question though becomes
then who is a squatter and that's a
complicated question and one of the
things that I urge this committee to do
I believe we could work it out uh as
Nick Nick Norman suggested even you know
the landlords too recognize that
throwing people out of their homes
precipitously without without a lease
and without without process is uh is bad
policy but um but understand
that I can't see any basis for such a
somewhat complicated issue to be decided
upon on such short notice I mean
whatever the problems we have with the
current law have existed for at least
the last 30 8
years so what is what's the emergency
that is driving this so I would really
urge you to to hang on to either send it
to study or have somebody bring it back
uh next session but let me just
highlight a few of the problems that you
if if as you go through your work
session you can think about first and
foremost by requiring a written
agreement as a requirement of ATT
tendency
it the bill totally eliminates the law
of implied contracts in the context of
landlord tenant law there are two t
kinds of implied contracts one is an
implied in fact contract which is based
on inferences drawn from the behavior of
the parties for example a girlfriend
moves in at the request of the of her
boyfriend who's a lawful tenant the
landlord says okay if you pay me an
additional $50 there's nothing in
writing to uh about moving the uh the
girlfriend in um the tenant agrees they
pay and after 6 months or so the there's
domestic violence and the quote lawful
tenant moves out um and the girlfriend
is in the apartment she's been there
knowingly for for six months but under
but she doesn't have her written rental
agreement under the amendment or any
such requirement she's going to be
subjected to being forcibly
removed arrested charged with criminal
trespass and and perhaps convicted
without any notice
whatsoever I hate to but that's just
again I know it's not intended but
that's the kind of situation that's
going to be opened up and this is also
true a lot of especially elderly tenants
don't have Elites if and especially
those who are renting from
nonprofessional landlords and if they po
the same problem was posed for them or a
college student who comes back after he
graduates with no job and unfortunately
that's happening more and more in this
in this Society uh parents moved to
Florida he was there knowingly for
months and months if not years uh
landlord gets unhappy Bingo he's gone
because he didn't have a written
agreement that is not going to work and
especially when you pile this on with
arrest um for trespass impossible
conviction without any notice
whatsoever regardless of the intent the
amendment would strip Untold number of
New Hampshire citizens of their
legitimate rights as tenants without any
opportunity to ex to explain their claim
of tenancy to a judge it would
precipitously throw throw them into the
most difficult housing market the state
has ever seen and make them criminals
for per and for perfectly legitimate
Behavior nothing in the current law TS a
person who moves into a home or remains
there without permission of the owner or
a lawful tenant it's trespass pure and
simple under RSA 635 section
2 notwithstanding the chatter in the
media there's nothing happening in New
Hampshire that warrant dealing with this
issue outside of the normal legislative
process and that's what I urge you to do
I'd be happy to answer any questions so
Mr Barry I just um if you could you had
talked about
if a if a tenant says Hey can my can my
significant other come live with me and
the landlord says sure $50 a month and
it's a verbal
agreement if we could turn the table for
a minute and what happens what is the
process when the tenant stops paying the
$50 and the Tenant says well there's
nothing in writing that says that I had
to pay this
$50 yes well then you have a a uh a
hearing in court to determine whether
the parties ever agreed to that my guess
is in most cases they're going to be
canceled checks or maybe I'm an oldtime
maybe Nobody Does that anymore but rent
receipts and the judge will decide
whether there was whether or not there
was an agreement and that's what you
know that's one of the things that's
sorely missing here is the opportunity
for an alleged unauthorized tenant to
establish that he or she is an
authorized tenant and could you just
give us the the time frames for those
you know 30 days for this 20 days for
this sure the vast majority of evictions
are non-payment and they're going to be
so in your example you'd get a 7-Day
eviction notice followed up by a court
process that's probably going to take
about 30 days from beginning to end um
for other cases if it were for
unauthorized tenant which you can
certainly bring an eviction for in this
state the eviction notice would provide
30 days prior notice and then a an
additional court
process so so the the seven days for
yeah for non-payment for damage or
behavior which material adversely
affects the health and safety of another
tenant 30 days in all other cases okay
so if if you could so my understanding
is you have to notify the person of the
eviction
and so what once they receive the
notification for the eviction do they is
it 30 days that they have
to yeah 30 days some will move out
within those 30 days some will wait
until the they are served after the 30
days they'll be served with a Summons to
go to court called the landlord tenant
RIT and then they'll they'll fight it
out in court as to whether they're that
non-payment or the 30-day whether they
are in fact an unauthorized tenant okay
so 30 days and then they can go to court
yes and then they have to wait for their
court date yeah which are
pretty normally that court date is going
to be
about between I think 10 and 20 days
after the hearing I'm sorry after Ser
after service of process normally but
somewh
longer okay so the reality is the the 7
Days the 30 days the 20 days is would
you say reasonably a 45 five 50
days if it's for a 30-day eviction as
opposed to non-payment 7day um then yeah
I think that's probably right okay thank
you can I just add one thing certain if
I might your questions underscore that
there's a lot more going on here that
you're that you're being asked to deal
with than just what's covered in the
amendment and I think that uh I think
that just underscores the need for to
have this done in the normal
deliberative process okay thank
Newman thank you um a question I have is
I I noticed in the amendment that it
authorizes police officers to use
reasonable force during the eviction
process itself um I know that uh
currently this is a a civil matter where
sheriffs are used um that's absolutely
do you have I mean do you have any
concerns about authorizing police
officers to use any level of force in in
these matters I do I have and my only
parenthetical to that is I've never
practiced any criminal law and I am I'm
not um it's not my area of expertise but
do followup could you elaborate on that
a little bit yeah I mean again if the
people who are very experienced in in
serving what they call rits of
possession the document that the
landlord takes to actually remove uh the
tenant uh as you said those are sheriffs
and I don't I think that they're the
ones who are experienced enough to know
how to get it done in the maximally safe
way I think you know the Poli you bring
the police into the process uh and I
think their orientation is is a lot
different and their experience is a lot
different and I just think it it
heightens it heightens the tensions
around a very tense uh event in the life
sheriffs representative Newman I
apologize I meant to say representative
Muse when I said your name earlier
representative Reed thank you madam
chair so what would your ideal how would
you ideally remove
um people who don't want to leave if you
don't use sheriffs or law en oh no I'm
not it this happens let I I was checking
this the other day um there were
actually about
3500 uh rits of possession issued where
the in the past year where the sheriff
goes and and peaceably removes the
tenant um It's a situation that happens
almost every day uh and I'm you know I
think un unfortunately that's something
that has to happen so I'm not opposed to
that this issue of how much force ought
to be used uh and who's the best to uh
to figure out a way to remove those
tenants I think that's a more
complicated
question Mr Barry I just have one more
question what is
the what are the the
months my understanding is I'm not sure
if it's just the winter months if it's
like October through April ail November
through April that a a person is not
allowed to be evicted in New Hampshire
for the winter if I can just tell you a
very brief anecdote uh after about five
years of practice uh where tenant where
people especially um mothers with
children would come into my office and
they'd say I got this eviction notice
but I can't be evicted because it's
winter time and finally I heard it so
often that I worked with a sponsor of to
get a sponsor for a bill to say you
can't evict somebody in the winter time
it is not now and never has been the law
evictions go through every month of the
year okay thank you representative
Newman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question could you
just briefly talk about the part of
five4 40 that's being amended now that
talks about evictions in 7 days and 30
days notice just kind of to help us
understand when there's a dispute and
the money is not paid sure and then
something happens in that what point in
that process would it come to the point
where a force a a rid of possession
would be used to get them out of the
property sure so all EV all lawful
evictions start with the issuance by the
landlord of something called an eviction
notice used to be called a notice to
quit that it's going to be other seven
days gives a 10 it says you have be have
to vacate the premises by either seven
days from service or 30 days it's seven
days if it's non-payment of rent damage
or behavior which materially affects the
health and safety of another tenant or
the landlord those are seven days
everything else is 30 days if the tenant
remains in the premises after after the
date on the eviction notice says they
have to vacate by then the landlord
serves what they call a landlord tenant
RIT which is a summons to go to court
the tenant usually has seven days from
the state of service to file an
appearance which is the equivalent of
asking for a hearing the hearing will
usually be set 10 to 15 days uh
sometimes less minimum of seven
sometimes up to 15 days later uh and
then after the hearing if the landlord
prevails the landlord um there a what
they call a rid of possession will issue
uh on the eth day following the hearing
and then the sheriff serves that rid of
possession and the Tenant is hopefully
not on the street but all too many times
in these days they
are
followup and if uh the bill was written
substantially to have that or as written
right now takes all of that due process
away is that correct for tenants who
don't have written um leases or rental
agreements of which there are many thank
you thank you very much Mr Barry thank
welcome back thank you so much uh and
thank you uh to all the committee for
taking my testimony today my name is
Grace K I'm the program coordinator with
the American friends service committee
um and a longtime New Hampshire resident
uh living in Manchester um so I'll keep
my my comments brief I think there have
been far more expert Witnesses who have
come before to testify um but I'll
simply say that um that I I understand
that the amendment will be changed and
so I'm really speaking to more the
spirit and the intent of this bill and
to really urge the committee to take
into consideration um the vulnerability
of the populations who will be affected
by a bill an amendment such as this um
and I absolutely um um underscore the
the comments that um the gentleman
before me spoke of of the importance of
recognizing that this is a very complex
issue and giving it the care and I know
that this committee as is so often does
will give it that care and attention um
that is needed to unders underscore the
complexity and so I just wanted to talk
about just very briefly the importance
of balancing intent over impact and
recognizing what is the problem that is
trying to be solved by this bill um I
have the privilege of being a homeowner
um but I've been a long I was a longtime
tenant and renter for the majority of my
life living up here in New Hampshire as
well as when I was living in Boston I've
had um I've unfortunately had the
experience both as a child um and as an
adult to undergo eviction processes to
witness eviction processes which are
very difficult and painful experiences
for anyone who's ever has ever gone
through that themselves or has witnessed
it and so again thinking about um the
impact that this bill will have on
already vulnerable people as we're
talking about people who are you know in
situations where they are living without
a formal lease um whether that be family
members um whether that be partners
whether that be and especially
particularly think about um within my
own community bipac community immigrant
bipo Community here in New Hampshire
where because of our housing um a lack
of affordable housing we do have people
living multiple people more people
living in a home um than their our
bedroom simply because that's what
people have to do in order to ensure
that you know they can they can survive
that they have a place that they can put
their head down that is safe and free uh
from the elements and so I just really
urge the committee to really take into
consideration again like what is the
intent you know the intent of this bill
what is the impact that will have on our
New Hampshire residents that this this
committee is tasked with safety
Community safety within our state and
does it make us more safe is it just to
put forward an amendment that would um
needlessly harm and burden tenants who
are in situations that are already
vulnerable is it the committee's goal to
make life harder for already vulnerable
populations or is it the committee's
goal to ensure that those vulnerable
populations are protected while also
balancing the interest of our landlord
Community as well as our other um and
other interests in that and so I just
wanted to just really come up here and
really urge the committee to think to
really take into consideration
especially considering what bill this
particular amendment is attached to and
that there are better ways for us to
approach the needs of um balancing
different interest ensuring that um we
are securing housing that we are
creating safe communities but targeting
already vulnerable populations who will
undergo already um difficult processes
in creating uh uh process in such a way
that their own rights are not protected
that we are deputizing landlords to
remove tenants that we are sort of
putting a vulnerable class of people
sort of outside the law um I think is is
is very alarming and so I look forward
to seeing the uh new language for this
bill I look forward to representative
RADS um introducing that and I look
forward to being able to uh uh testify
on that as well but again and the
crafting of this I really strongly urge
you to take into consideration that
Public Safety means Public Safety for
all thank
you and I'm happy to take questions if
there are
any I don't see any thank you very much
thank
thank you I'm represent Timothy Horgan
and actually came in today for bills
down the hall on education but hopefully
I can add something to debate I'm I
usually sit on the house Judiciary
Committee which usually gets uh bills
about evictions and we get them every
year um and the so there's always a uh
we always get bills to make eviction uh
easier and that's not necessarily a good
thing this goes way farther than
anything else that's ever been submitted
so like if um you know if the sponsor
the sponsor thinks is a good idea they
probably be better off waiting till the
next filing period And if the re-elected
they can bring it back in 2025 believe
me we've seen lots of bills about this
about this before I know um I do know
like at least one or two of my
constituents I'm Timothy Horan from
Durham um so but one to 20 people are
worried about it um and they say there
scores of stories which show why this
bill is needed um I have not heard any
of those scores of stories if if you
wait till next year submit it we'll have
like the usual process would take
several months and perhaps we can hear
and evaluate those scores of stories so
right now I I see nothing that says this
pill is needed it goes like very far
especially we get law enforcement
involved you know before there's any
proof like whose property it is or
whether you know whether they actually
even deserve to be evicted especially
the part about taking people's property
and letting the owner dispose of it as a
see fit that's uh that's like a very
extreme measure and I might also add
since this is in criminal justice and I
know there's several Second Amendment
very second amendment stall wordss in
here there's no carve out in here for
firearms that the that are abandoned um
so there's uh that's probably a reason
of right there to either that's
something maybe you might try to amend
that bill to put in a car off for
firearms but I think that's probably a
reason enough right there for many
people on this committee to vote no on
this amendment you know people's guns
can be taken away and all their other
property but I know at least in some
people's minds guns are special you know
there's even more valuable than other
properties so I would just
say I say this amendment is premature if
you think it's a good idea I say wait
till next year um the Judiciary
Committee can deal with them as we deal
with these bills every year and I'm also
like not particularly enthusiastic about
the underlying bill either but um that's
a matter for another day and most of
these squatters we're supposed to be
worried about are not going to be
necessarily undocumented immigrants
anyway most uh most tenants are citizens
or uh you know green card holders but so
that's that's basically why I think this
a was a terrible idea so I urge you to
uh urge you to kill it so I'd be happy
seeing none thank you yes so if I'm back
in judiciary next year if I get
reelected I'm I'm sure I'll see more
eviction bills so thanks thank you
representative I would like the public
to know that the sponsor of the
amendment is not the one that makes the
decision of where the bills are heard
whether it's criminal justice or
Judiciary is there anybody that wishes
to testify on the amendment that has not
turned in a pain card seeing none I will
close the public
hearing for the amendment 20241
1484 the committee will take a 15-minute
11:15
e
okay we're going to start our work
session on the underlying bill with
regards to the amendment we were just
talking about um that amendment is going
to actually go away and a new Amendment
will be drafted for a non gerain for
another bill and then we'll have another
public hearing on it next week um so
here the amendment the non-gain
amendment that we just heard um is going
to um we're going to we're going to get
rid of that and there'll be a new
non-gain Amendment attached to a new
bill that will hear next week so it'll
be like a doover
so the bill that we just heard we're
going to we're going to throw it out
bill yeah 563 is still going forward
though um so we're going to be talking
now the am the bill
itself that's a work session for the
it said both okay
qu I thought it did question for the
chair yes sir could you so what you just
said and you said it pretty fast we we
will have a non-gain Amendment and it
will not be associated with this bill be
associated with another bill that is
correct thank you very much and we'll
take that up next week that's fine thank
you and it will be properly noticed I
appreciate that is correct but it' be a
n for 563 no 563 is now we're going to
just deal with 56 de with as the bill as
introduced yeah I'm cutting cutting that
loose everybody understand
okay I would think
so all right just as a generality on the
on the underlying bill I think we're all
in agreement that it is um very very
very very broad um um there there pieces
of that bill I understand what the they
were going for um but this thing about
um using
does anyone have a copy of 563 yeah
could I could I see your copy okay I got
it
thanks um with
particularly the part that I found very
Troublesome that said law enforcement
agency shall use its best efforts to
support the enforcement of federal
immigration law I found that extremely
disturbing um it's broad it does what
what does that even mean um
we we've
repeatedly said that we want to limit
Federal involvement in our in or our low
enforcements um interactions as far as
enforcing federal law so I feel like
this bill is very um over Brad in that
respect so does everyone pretty much
agree with that that that section is
problematic anyone else want to discuss
talk about
that no you guys are okay with
it okay
either
that okay
so I think that in the effort of of
we're going to look the rest of it just
seems to be more um more to do with
definitions than anything what I'm I'm
proposing that the only thing that we
should be doing is
prohibiting um
prohibiting law enforcement from being
allowed to cooperate with regard to
detainers in other words I don't want
law enforcement asking anyone their
citizenship status or any of that stuff
if someone's arrested for a New
Hampshire crime and they're booked
during the process of the booking for a
violation of the Hampshire law it
becomes evident that there's an ice
detainer I think our law enforcement
should honor that detainer but as far as
inquiries about someone's citizenship
before their there for another reason uh
that goes way too far as far as I'm
concerned and um that goes for this
thing about um shall use best efforts I
feel like that's overly broad further
discussion representative
scitec it sounds like you're proposing a
one- sentence
Amendment uh pretty close to it I would
think
yeah further discussion
represent Manion thank you just throwing
this out there so if you uh have
occasion to run across somebody for
traffic violation you don't arrest them
however you run their name and a
detainer pops up are we prohibiting law
enforcement from acting on that detainer
even though the person isn't under
arrest or any New Hampshire offenses it
depends there's several kind of
detainers in my understanding there's
criminal detainers and civil detainers
is that
correct I'm not sure yeah I think we
would need to find that out if it's if
it's if it's a warrant then I would say
no they have to a warrant but if it's if
you have them in custody any anyway
could you please notify us type of thing
that's different I don't think that we
would be arresting on detainers um
because they're not a criminal it's not
a necessarily a criminal warrant so if
there's a criminal warrant then yes if
there's a ice detainer I think they can
notify ice that they've been in contact
with that person but they can't take
them into custody based on a
detainer but I I am going to ask that to
make sure but I believe that is the
state of the
Muse yeah I'm I'm not sure that uh that
fixing that one particular area actually
uh fixes this legislation um one of the
other things that this particular uh
this particular Bill does is it uh it it
essentially functions as a uh as an
unfunded mandate on local Law
Enforcement Officers um
and unless we remove things like all of
section uh basically the the things that
are uh listed in section six of the bill
so uh forcing local law enforcement to
comply with an immigration retainer uh
complying with a request from a federal
immigration agency to notify the agency
providing uh Federal immigration agency
access to inmates for interviews
participating in any program or
agreement authorized under Section 287
of the immigration and nationality act
whatever that is um there's just a lot
of stuff here in in this particular Bill
uh and a lot of things that our police
officers I I don't believe are are
trained for uh at this St Point um and I
think similar to the issue that was
raised on the um uh on on the on the
squatter Bill once again we have uh you
know New Hampshire police officers and
Law Enforcement Officers sort of thrust
into situations uh that they don't have
experience with and that they're not
trained for um and that creates
situations where we could have a lot of
unintended consequen
quences um I think the other thing
that's worth noting in the context of
this particular bill is um you know we
are not Texas we're not Arizona we are
not uh a border state um and the need uh
for this I I think one of the things we
always have to ask ourselves as a
legislators is whether or not there's
actually a need for a particular Bill
what's what's the problem uh that we're
that we're trying to solve and I think
the problem that we're trying to solve
with this particular bill um is that Fox
News has non-stop 247 coverage of the
Southern border crisis and that we would
kind of like to have our own little
piece of it here in New Hampshire uh and
unfortunately I just think that it
creates uh a lot of additional problems
uh that we're not prepared to solve at
this
point well I would say I watched this
morning and they weren't covering the
Border crisis they were covering the um
unconstitutional persecution of
President Trump for a little while um
but that being
said we have a southern border with a
state that advertised itself as a as a
sanctuary State and they have actually
screamed out for help because they've
overwhelmed themselves with their number
of unduped immigrants so um we are
beginning to see an influx into our
state and we are a border state State we
actually border Canada um so I don't
know what the Southern versus northern
border has to do with it but it's a
border but I feel like if we limit this
down to things that are already being
done I'm quite sure we do have training
in complying with an immigration
detainer um that's not a unfunded
mandate um complying with requests for
to notify them that's a phone call
that's not unfunded mandate providing uh
Federal immigration access to interview
an inmate also no cost there and
participating in any program or
agreement authorized by federal law um
I'm not sure what that means in all
honesty so I am going to look it up I
wouldn't advocate for that until I know
what it means and providing fidal
immigration agency with inmates
incarceration status or release date
also no cost to let them know when the
person's expected to be released
representative Manion thank you Mr chair
yeah on that note as far as unfunded
mandates uh we hold people on war inside
of Massachusetts New York California all
the time
and there's no extra funding to hold
that person ice detainer is no different
you're holding somebody for another
agency whether it's 24 hours or 48 Hours
um I've heard a lot today about the lack
of training our local police have and
that only sheriffs know how to evict
people from property and only the
federal government knows how to deal
with ice detainers that's incorrect we
go to the same Police Academy as the
sheriff's we have the same training
sometimes more training there's training
on Ice detainers there's training on
federal law there's training on local
law and state law uh and evictions as
well criminal trespass is Criminal
Trespass whether it's a sheriff
enforcing it or a local police enforcing
it so um as far as training goes the
training is there just to dispel
anyone's uh suspicion of otherwise but
it is also not a unfunded mandate the
money's there it's already being done in
your experience um have you held ice
detainers have you had any interaction
when your experience with ice as far as
them coming to talk to people or
anything like
that I have not personally but my agency
has and um like I said it's within 204
to 48 hours and outside of that they'll
they'll be released if they don't pick
them up but it's no different than if
Massachusetts has a warrant for somebody
and uh we we hold them for them and they
scenario the role we would play is just
notifying them that we have someone in
custody for another crime um so again I
don't see how this is um this is would
cost anymore um all it's doing is
complying with federal law and and
assisting the our federal Partners um
without inconveniencing the hampsher
citizens because we're not going to be
asking them any of these things unless
they've been arrested front of the crime
further discussion
representative oh oh
Linda go
ahead uh I have had several uh ice
detainers and it's a simple phone call
they'll either say let them go or hold
them uh one of my cases was a hondur
national big time drug cartel dealer you
could not even tell he was super nice I
ran them they said we'll be down in
about 5 minutes they came from uh the
conquered office they'll also come down
from Vermont that's all it is is a phone
call and they say yeah yay or nay and
that's it there's no sort of unfunded
mandate
whatsoever is there any time limit as
far as how long they can take to come
get
him that would be a court issue uh it's
that reasonableness how long to detain
someone roadside is kind of the call of
myself or the ice agent they were always
there very quickly so I can't speak on
the actual time limit for that so that's
a roadside stop where they came up as a
detainer and you called from the side of
the road and they asked yes it was for
like a speeding violation I ran the guy
he gave me his his information and it
popped up on the screen immigration
enforcement hit call this number I would
call and either a y or a and that was it
okay um representative herck gather
thank you
um Mr chair for taking my question but
I'm concerned about this bill and
particularly the original bill because
we heard so much testimony even from our
police
department and I I struggle with that
because um we've counted on them in so
many aspects of the law and how we treat
people and those types of things and um
when they say to us that right now today
if someone is um have committed a
crime you know they get the regular
treatment like anyone else it doesn't
matter so if that's the case why are we
still doing this with this bill so again
this bill just seems like it's trying to
solve a problem that really doesn't
exist here for
us we've had many um the border control
we've had the come before us over the
last couple months for different reasons
and and no one has ever said there was a
problem not
one not even a law enforcement that was
in that area near the
borders with all the bills that we have
heard this year so I guess for me I'm
really struggling with this bill the
fact that it's even
here didn't we hear correct me if I'm
wrong I believe we heard there was a
mass murderer that was hiding right in
our was that is that did we yeah yeah in
Ry so that's that's new hampsh sry I
think that's a problem um yeah but
there's teally the V and all those
people hiding too who it depend on what
you look like come on I don't think mass
murder is um anything to do with race at
all that was one case of a mass murderer
how many mass murderers do we need
represent
say thank you um just a point of
clarification so it feels to me like
we're having an executive session
talking about the mer and I'm just
trying to clarify what are purposes in a
work session in terms of what are we
hoping to get out of this time today
just because I'm I couldn't fully hear
what you're saying at the beginning it I
don't know it was the audit the rumor
myself but I'm just trying to figure out
our is our goal that we're trying to see
if we can find an amendment to this bill
we can all agree on or are we just
debating the merits of the
bill I think both of those two things um
a work session is so that the committee
can come together and look at it and say
is there anything in this bill um that
we could make better that that would
make it um serve a purpose that would be
justifiable um okay and and INF further
the public safety may I thank you so
much so I have to say I I have objection
to the underlying premise of the bill
that that we have all of these
challenges and part of the reason for
that is you know I have relatives who
attempted to come over here in the 1920s
and 30s
and their boats were turned away because
they were um threats to this country um
and and so they are no longer my
relatives because they all ended up back
on the other side of the ocean and then
in gas camps um if if we continue to
have policies that are anti-immigrant
anti-human and
anti-human I think It ultimately creates
major problems the majority I'm not
saying every immigrant but the majority
of people who are immigrants to this
country whether they come documented or
start out documented and become
undocumented or whether they ultimately
come here without documentation the
majority of them are coming because they
are desperately trying to find a way to
better their lives and I feel like bills
like this puts them in a category of
making them less than human and puts
them in a category where it's easy for
people to um discriminate against people
purely because they're trying to get out
of a desperate situation
it's your position that if someone has a
detainer on them from ice because
they've broken a law be it not showed up
for their hearing or or any number of
laws that Isis put a detainer on and
that includes also convictions for other
crimes and other
jurisdictions that makes them Less in
human no my premise is the way that this
bill is written it refers to people
using language I personally find
offensive oh yeah but we're talking
about changing it so I I understand that
but I find that the underlying premise
of the bill is one that dehumanizes
people so the premise of the bill is
that there in my understanding because I
didn't write it is that there are
several communities in the state that
have declared themselves so-called
Sanctuary States uh cities and they
they've prohibited their police
departments from cooperating with ice so
the premise of the bill that is that as
a state we don't want our cities and
towns deciding which federal laws
they're going to let their police
officers IGN we've also decided as a
State we're not going to enforce a
number of other federal laws we're not
enforcing federal law though here that's
what I want to change I want to make
sure we're not enforcing it we're just
recognizing it but we we've determined
that we're not going to recognize other
federal laws so which ones we there are
number of gun laws that we've decided
we're not going to which
ones we we are not dealing with guns in
schools appropriately people walk with a
gun in a school but we can't do anything
to enforce it based on laws that we
passed until they actually start to fire
federal law and guns and schools is
unless you have a license carry you
can't bring and G in a school so we
enforce that law I
disagree I mean I just I don't want to
conflate lawful
immigration or actually even unlawful
immigration this is this is we're
talking about dealing with people that
who this ice under this president has
said should be held we're asking you to
hold these for us and we have cities and
towns are saying no so I mean does that
that that doesn't seem be a safe way to
run a state or a country if we can't get
people that the federal authorities are
saying hey we find this person um needs
to be held be they on a terrorist watch
list a a mass murderer or or they just
didn't show up for their court hearing
if if someone has a thing out for being
a mass murderer or for being um I foret
what the other term you just used was
aside from their immigration status
presumably there is a different type of
retainer as well about them having
violated some major crime
well that's what I was asking him imra
yeah is there a difference between a uh
a detainer for um for example missing
your court date versus a detainer War
you've committed a crime therefore
absolutely but just as just as there
should be you know if someone were to be
in Massachusetts beating a a partner and
be guilty of of domestic assault and
having fled to New Hampshire that person
should be held just in the in the same
way yeah sure go ahead so in that case
in Ry the the crimes were committed in
Brazil I believe so we have no Authority
or no uh jurisdiction there so there
would be no warrant or anything else for
us to arrest him on that crime in Brazil
this is strictly a detainer because of
the person he was that he was held on
and Ice wanted him so different than
Massachusetts and we we honored that and
send him back we didn't hold him because
of that and and we have a lot of people
committing crimes and murders in this
state and in other States in this
country who are lawful US citizens and
it happens all the time but what if that
person was in a city or a town that
prohibited their police from detaining
that
person then there's still ways that ice
handles it oh if they don't know the
person exists representative Reed thank
you Mr chairman I think um we need I
like to look at it this way um you know
we're Public Safety right and we're
protecting the Immigrant Community as
well because people come here the the
legitimate people come here for peaceful
productive life we're allowing people in
with that don't that have nefarious
histories or motive they're hiding in
these communities I feel if they're stop
if somebody's stopped and they have a
retainer we're not only protecting the
public at as a whole but we're also
protecting the IM immigrant communities
from people who will be in those
communities and possibly posing a threat
but because we're not calling I to um
decide if they should um come for them
or not we're put in a community at risk
who would not ordinarily reach out to
law enforcement and those um people are
hiding in the community potentially
harming those communities who will not
speak out and I use the example of uh
migrant workers in North Carolina that
come in to harvest the tobacco coton
whatever they're a quiet community that
sticks to themselves yet we have people
coming in um from Venezuela um MS13 and
they're infiltrating those communities
those communities aren't going to say
anything I feel that it's the police
that it's a safety thing that if
somebody's picked up they have a
detainer that I should be notified and
it should be dealt with it protects
everybody involved legal or not or
otherwise and I think I want to
reiterate it's important to know we're
not proposing or whatever the bill says
it it wouldn't coming out of this
committee proposed that our law
enforcement ask anybody about their
immigration status at any point um prior
to their being arrested and being
flagged in the system as being wanted um
so the this you know we had some um
letters from police Chiefs and I gave
those their their due attention and it
talked about you know interfering in the
in the relationships they built in their
communities and I think that's
invaluable I wouldn't want our police to
start going into communities start
asking people their immigration status
um that's why we have a a federal agency
that handles that but this is
specifically talking about once someone
is violated a New Hampshire law taken
into custody for that or stopped for a
violation of New Hampshire law and an
ice detainer is is is um flagged in
their system at that point what we're
saying to the officer if we are in one
of these Sanctuary towns is ignore that
and I I I can't in good conscience say
to the citizens of New Hampshire this
person's wanted federally we're not sure
for what exactly it could be anything
from murder to to whatever and we're
just going to ignore that and let them
go um that seems incredibly Reckless and
it shows a disregard for the federal
court system the federal law enforcement
system um and I just don't see how we
can justify that is as long as we keep
it where in the lane it belongs which is
someone who has already been processed
assessed by this ice agency and they
have a lawful um detainer on that person
it's not just us randomly picking people
up representative
Murphy oh thank you um not relative to
the merits of the bill actually but just
to the financial impacts I am aware and
I don't have all the specifics I wish I
did but I know in marac there's actually
a lawsuit against the marac police
department for their efforts um
regarding they they attempted they did
uh detain somebody for ice and Ice EV
didn't show up um and um so I and I I
wish I'd have to get all the specifics
but I do know that they are involved in
a in a lawsuit um so it is costing you
know a municipality um like trying to to
do that yeah I I can you give me that
information sure thank you very much
because that would be important to know
um representative
Muse one of the things I just want to
make sure we're all on the same page
about is we're not necessarily talking
about um rapists murderers and
kidnappers we're also talking about
people uh who might run a stop sign um
we're talking about people who might be
uh uh arrested or cited on a violation
level offense um and one of the things
that I want to call everybody's
attention to is the the letter that uh
Chief aldenberg uh my police chief and
several other police Chiefs uh sent to
us that basically said and I'll read it
I'll read you one paragraph to be clear
police officers already possess the
ability and authority to enforc
violations of local state and federal
criminal statutes indeed all police
departments in New Hampshire coordinate
with federal agencies to apprehend
individuals no matter what their
citizenship status who may have engaged
in crimes but in our humble opinion as
law enforcement practitioners this
legislation is unnecessary and would
prohibit agency from promulgating and
implementing policies and procedures
that suit the needs of the communities
they serve one of the things that these
police Chiefs are actually trying to
protect our relationships with members
of the community uh and in many cases
vulnerable members of the community that
have been very hard one uh over a long
period of time um uh and that I and that
they that they clearly feel uh would be
inject
if we passed a bill like this so you
know I I I realize we do have some
former police officers uh who are on the
uh the criminal justice and Public
Safety Committee and I rep I respect
their opinions and I respect their their
expertise uh but we also have uh people
who are in law enforcement now who have
contacted us on this issue and have
weighed in decisively against it
thank
you thank you um you're you're correct
they did weigh indecisively um as it is
written and I would be um interested in
in possibly changing that but we have to
we can't pick and choose when we take
their advice they also said it was a
horrible idea to legalize a possession
of 10 milligrams or more of a of a
controlled substance and we voted
against that so um I think that we have
to be pretty uniform Whose advice we
take and for what um but again I would
want to change and limit it strictly to
and this is happening this isn't um you
know they may say in their departments
it's not happening but we heard from the
senator that this is happening um in
several departments where they have been
ordered not to honor or notify ice um
and and that if that's happening that
type of lawlessness can't be can't be
allowed in our state because where you
have one you're only strong as your
weakest link and if we have one town
that is not honoring detainers from the
federal government
and you can't have a ice detainer for
running a stop sign that's that's not
how that works um if they're ignoring
Ice
detainers by not even calling to say
that we have this person um I I feel
like we're we're putting our entire
citizenry at risk um by rolling the dice
assuming it's not an important thing and
that they won't go on to hurt anyone
after they've been released
representative Manion thank you Mr chair
I just want to go on record uh to
because I've been asked to let everyone
know that I'm currently in law
enforcement I'm not a former law
enforcement off officer I still in
currently employed as an law officer
just so everyone's aware of that before
I give any more testimony or anything
thank you okay representative
Newman oh you good all um oh
representative new sorry that happens to
representative Murray too I never see
Too Close can't see me over here um I
believe uh part of the testimony that we
heard is that um there are no Sanctuary
cities and that's what the law
enforcement um officers were trying like
in the way that we Define them so we're
defining law uh Sanctuary cities in
different ways right
um we keep saying that uh there wouldn't
be a detainer issued unless it were for
a serious offense for the serious
offenses it would seem that even in
sanctuary cities um people are being
held for crimes regardless of their
immigration status or anything like that
so it comes back to the point why are we
why are we doing this like why are we
putting this in place because it seems
that it is not needed it is unnecessary
and at the end of the day what it seems
like um or or the impact of it the
effect of it would be um further
criminalizing and inhibiting um
participation from very vulnerable um
members of our community that we talk
about um if we talk about Public Safety
those are the people that were those are
part of the people that we're trying to
protect and yet we're putting them in a
situation
um you know
unnecessarily and you know with this
kind of frame of mind of something that
isn't actually happening we're putting
something in place that further inhibits
people um from from um fully
participating in our society and in in
fully uh advocating for themselves as
well um and the public safety part of
that of course not only individually and
not only in um many different
communities in part of our our broader
Community but also in the fact that if
you actually want to um be able to um
know and have people feel comfortable
speaking up about something that is
going wrong about someone who is
actually potentially dangerous or
harmful people need to feel comfortable
in coming and speaking with law
enforcement so we're having I feel like
we're having this conversation about
like that having this conversation about
an issue that isn't even really an issue
at this point in the impact of us acting
as if it is and putting further language
in our in our uh statutes around
something that isn't happening is is um
is worsening uh is worsening Public
Safety rather than um increasing or
fixing it yeah
okay okay so the the the proposal that I
um that I'm making yeah uh you may I'm
just going to respond to what she said
uh um The Proposal that I'm making with
regard to only the ice detainer portion
of it um would have no impact whatsoever
on the relationships with the
communities on the protected people not
feeling safe the only time that would
even come up is if they were under
arrest for a violation of of a of a law
so um I'm not sure how any of that stuff
would apply to a situation where our law
enforcement was mandated to um cooperate
on a nice detainer so I I understand
that as members of our community first
of all it's not up to us to decide who
or who is not in our community that's up
to the federal government and if they're
here the federal government let them be
here they're entitled to the same
protection by law enforcement of
everyone else so once we find however
through an arrest that they are wanted
by immigration I feel like we need to
honor that as part of the cooperation
between the state and federal government
um but your point is taken
representative
scitec um I'd like to re perhaps focus a
little bit more on what you just said uh
there's after you blow all there's a lot
of foam here but very little beer uh I
don't think any of this is necessary uh
I think the situation in New Hampshire
is working fine the only thing I want to
prevent is the aggre if it exists the
aggressive Pro prohibition that the
local police department won't honor a
ice detainer I have no other interest in
the
bill I agree wholeheartedly that's
basically what I would like to narrow it
down to is as a matter of fact I'm even
I'm even even willing to um get rid of
all the sanctuary words I mean that's
really irrelevant to me I just want to
make sure that they're honoring the law
um further discussion representative um
Jamber thank you um I want to point out
a few things here and I better start
with I'm an elected law enforcement
officer
um if somebody is pulled over for
breaking a motor vehicle law which would
have violation
level and the police officer goes back
to the cruiser runs their uh
history and it shows that they have a
warrant out of
Connecticut that police officer is
immediately going to call Conneticut and
say are you going to come and get them
for extradition well they not may not
get an answer right away so what does
that police officer do they let him go
no they take him into custody they honor
that arrest warrant out of a a foreign
uh
entity and they take him to the jail for
48 hours so if somebody has a warrant
out of California they're going to do
the same thing they have a warrant out
of Florida they're going to do the same
thing so there absolutely no reason
why uh if they run that background check
and they find that uh there's a detainer
from the immigration nationalization
service that they shouldn't hold them as
well so so we're talking about two
different things it it boils down to are
we going to
honor an
extradition agreement and I I think we
should
be well indeed you rais a good point um
by by refusing to cooperate with that
we're actually extending further um
protection to people who are wanted by
the federal government than we are
people who are wanted by our sister
States um if there's a fugitive from J
Justice warrant from another state we
hold the person but if it's an
immigration warrant from the federal
government we're going to ignore it that
that doesn't make any sense to me um on
any level I just can't wrap my mind
around how that would be good policy I
agree our our Law Enforcement Officers
should not be enforcing federal law um
but this isn't about enforcing federal
law this is about holding someone so
that the feds can enforce the federal
law and they've asked us to do so and it
seems to me that people who are coming
into the country in the last several
years have been granted um work
authorizations and all kinds of things
so that they probably are having proper
documentation so we should respect the
the same agency in other words you can't
say well it's great that they're letting
these folks in and giving them this
opportunity to get jobs but we're going
to ignore them when they say they want
them back for a reason it doesn't make
any sense representative Manion thank
you Mr chair I heard some discussion
about this not being needed because it's
not happening and we have no Sanctuary
cities did we not hear testimony last
week that there are some towns that
prohibit their law enforcement for
enforcing uh ice detainers or or do we
not hear
that okay thank
you um so this is what I'm talking about
kind of the definitions of like what is
a sanctuary City so um I'm sorry and I
wish I did to have uh uh you know an
example of this is what a sanctuary city
is actually my Sheriff spoke and um my
uh signed on to that letter and my
Sheriff um oversees my city which has is
what we would call a sanctuary City I
mean there's there are many different
communities that have um what they're
what they're doing is it's a resolution
to say that we are not going to go out
of our way um it it it comes back to the
idea of the definitions where we're
having a conversation about resolving an
issue that literally does not exist so
yes we can say there are uh uh cities
that have passed resolutions that say
that they are not going to encourage
their Law Enforcement Officers to go out
of their way um to um um to chase down
people and you know I'm sorry I'm not
putting it in the right in the proper
terminology but our definition of
whether or not even in those cities if
there is an ice detainer um thing that
is for something that is a serious crime
they will still be detained it's not
they're they're not getting away with
anything extra um that would be
something that you would keep somebody
from another state or something like
that it's we're we're we're talking
about different things we're talking in
circles because we're trying to resolve
an issue that doesn't exist in the first
place okay so first of all I disagree it
doesn't exist we heard we heard
testimony that there are towns that are
prohibiting their officers from honoring
ice detainers second of all I agree with
you I don't want to get into the
definition of sanctuary policies because
you're right some of them it may be so
innocuous as saying we're just a
welcoming Community versus some of them
that say we're not going to enforce any
federal law and we don't we don't care
if you're here um with papers or not so
I don't want to get into that matter of
fact I don't think it really belongs in
here I think what we should be doing is
just focusing on are there towns that
are prohibiting their officers
from um from enforcing or or notifying
ice that they have someone and if so
that's what we should address and if
it's not happening then you're correct
the bill doesn't need we don't need the
bill so um
we heard testimony albeit um second or
third hand that it is happening so I I
think I'd like to find out more about
that um I'd also like to find out from
representative Murphy the more details
about the mirat case so unless anyone
has anything else to add I think maybe
we should just um we we have until
Wednesday yeah go ahead I just was um
for specific clarification the
difference between a warrant and a
detainer um between those two terms
because I has detainers and we've been
talking about warrants from other states
so I just want to be really clear and
then I also wonder in regardless of the
specific answer of that question whether
the amendment could vacate the entire
contents of the bill and just say police
departments shall not be told not to
enforce federal law Bingo period I like
that that yeah we could yeah because at
the end of the day I think a lot of it
is um semantics so that doesn't really
go towards helping the law I I'm sorry I
can't I said Bingo um I think a lot of
that is just fluff and semantics that
don't necessarily contribute to
enforcing the law I'm not interested in
defining What sanctuary is and what
Sanctuary isn't I just want to know our
are are are our Law Enforcement Officers
being prohibited from cooperating with
the immigration and if they are that's
what we should address but shouldn't we
make it they could not just immigration
authorities any area like the DEA the um
the the I don't know there's like 10
billion different areas of government I
I any federal law enforcement agency
period I think that we already do um
with except for the law we specifically
passed exempting certain Firearms
regulations I don't think there's any
other thing that we don't cooperate with
but I could I could put that in there I
wouldn't have a problem with
that y i yes representative here Gap I
agree with the issue around the
different or I heard the same things
that you heard last week from folks that
said that however I have not had a law
enforcement person to say that so I I
feel as though that we're listening to
um some of the rhetoric that comes with
people as they discuss things however I
personally would love to hear that from
that police department or that chief of
police in whatever town or city they
claim is um actually ignoring the laws
or doesn't um hold people for retainers
I agree I'm going to make some inquiries
to see if I can get some actual Town um
yes represent so then we won't have to
say that this is a bill that doesn't
have any Merit so I just wanted to read
from you this is when I say that we are
um a sanctuary City welcoming committee
uh welcoming Community what this is what
I mean um and I'm just going to skip to
the jump this is the part where it says
now therefore be it resolved that the
city of Keane uh will encourage that uh
the following policies be adopted within
the city of Kean one to inquire into the
immigration or citizenship status of an
individual where the inquiry relates um
uh relates to a legitimate City purpose
uh as required by the federal state or
local law that is uh otherwise unrelated
to the enforcement of civil immigration
law two to only assist us uh Immigration
and Customs Enforcement um or Customs
and Border Protection in actions
intended to enforce Federal immigration
statutes when required to do so by a
federal state or local law that has been
deemed enforcable against the city or
required of the City by a Judicial Court
um uh with competent jurisdiction over
the city I'm sorry bad reading number
three this is the last one um to only
Cooper cooperate with ice or CBP um in a
request to detain or report an
individual when required to do so by
federal state or local law that has been
deemed enforcable against the city or
required by the city or Judicial Court
which competent over the city so what I
the the reason I want to say this this
is from 2017 so um this is a little bit
kind of prior to it uh becoming such a
um you know kind of sensationalized
issue in my opinion um but at the end of
the day I think that's that's the reason
why I feel like we're having such a
difficult conversation here and why
we're tring talking around circles in
circles is because what we're what we
are trying to um Implement in this law
is not actually resolving a problem that
exists
what it is doing is it is scaring people
who are in vulnerable communities and
creating um in my opinion um a much more
precarious situation for the public
safety of all of the members of our
community um because we are being kind
of uh ginned up to be uh to be concerned
about one or two mass murders and so um
I I think this
is unnecessary and
harmful well um I respect your opinion
having said that what you just read to
me is exactly why we need this law you
just said to me that our community will
not cooperate with ice unless there's a
state or federal law that says we have
to do so therefore I suggest that we may
need a state law to make your community
do that and I apologize for my bad
reading because I'm not sure I'll read
it that's all right okay um yeah sure
absolutely go
ahead well wanted to point out a couple
of things one thing is is
uh New Hampshire is not required under
federal law uh to support this in any
way uh no New Hampshire matter of fact
um no one no law enforcement agency is
any state in any state is required to
support an ice detainer and and I think
representative Cel made a great point
when she noted that there's a difference
between a warrant uh and a detainer uh
Federal immigration law is civil law it
is not criminal law
um and and I think one of the things
where we uh one one of the reasons why
I'm opposed to this is I continue to be
cautious when it comes to the very
slippery slope uh that we could be
headed down when we start authorizing uh
police officers uh to to do things in
the Civil area which which is what this
is um I think that there's a very
there's a very real danger that um
whatever we do uh is going to wind up
being challenged in the courts and
unfortunately our the particular process
that we're following uh on on this I
don't think is going to give us enough
time to get anything in this area right
um and I just think we need to be
extremely cautious about any changes in
this area especially when we're telling
people in communities that have put
together uh elected boards and elected
represent atives that have made
decisions based on the feedback they're
getting from members in their own
Community to enact policies like this um
this is one of those conquered things
where we're going to be telling people
you know in another community that oh no
you know once again you don't know best
we know best and we'll make the decision
for you um I'm pretty sure every single
one of our state laws does that criminal
law applies across the state I represent
Salem
Not Conquered or the state basically I
represent Salem and those are the people
that tell me what laws they want to see
enacted yeah I think that um with regard
to um civil versus criminal uh indeed
you are correct um most of the ice
things are civil um but a civil detainer
to pick somebody up doesn't mean that
they're wanted for a civil offense the
the the the prime example is the mass
murderer um who was working on on a roof
and Ry um you know he he it was a ice
detainer well that it was for murdering
multiple people so you can't just put a
blanket these are all civil we need to
leave them alone otherwise that
gentleman would still be working on
roofs in the community of Ry today so I
think we we do need to look at it though
carefully um representative Murphy thank
you just because I don't understand uh
how this works would it be possible to
your point that that you just made um
the difference between the the the
detainer and the warrant
in that situation with that murderer is
there a way for uh for a warrant to be
issued based on uh
um from an extra well from an out of
state um there is it's called a fugitive
from Justice warrant but for from
another country I'm not sure I think
that the detainer would be um what they
would use but I'm going to make
inquiries about that to if there's
another way I mean if if it's really
like that murderer if there was a Warr
Well yeah if there's a criminal detainer
versus a civil detainer I would say okay
then let's look at the criminal that's a
safety issue um so I want to see if
there's a difference thank you though
for that question all right with that
we're going to um recess and we're going
to um pick this up again on Wednesday I
believe we have scheduled for executive
session is that
correct yes okay so if if there's new
language to be brought um reach out to
me in the meantime I'm going to pursue
the Avenues I discussed and possibly
bring an amendment for us to disc
discuss at executive session with that